my channel is sponsored by anchorwork
which means we are going to have an ad
from them somewhere in this video
hello everyone i'm alana that's john and
that's jacob and we're playing through
elven ring we're going to play through
as much of the game as we possibly can
while jon's in town they're skipped but
we are aware that the camera will skip
in the first episode we we didn't notice
initially so there would be like an
occasional camera cut everything else
should be fine
episode two
it won't happen hopefully okay cool
enjoy oh we're so excited
oh
the game has motion blur by default they
all do
oh
okay oh my gosh
john
is the most important part of this whole
video game
so i believe we were talking we want to
go full decks with a little bit of magic
for our first playthrough how do you
guys feel about it that sounds cool wait
wait wait wait let's see what all the
options are yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
vagabond warrior is high health
balance strength and dex yeah
uh warrior is all dex that's a lot of
decks weird that's weird um hero
strength yeah vigor endurance strength
bandit
ooh a little bit of arcade in there
are you supposed to see profit
gaps under the bottom okay so mind faith
arcane and intelligence interesting what
are those i'm okay thank you the samurai
looks really cool
who is this
oh oh that's uh what's his name george
or i forget what it is
gerard
probably jerrod gerald yeah that he
became a meme on the subreddit amazing
um
all right so
what are you thinking
i mean i was thinking this hero or is
there one that has strength and magic
doesn't look like that's the thing is
arcane magic or his intelligence there's
like eight different
i would have thought it was arcane but
it might be so faith is faith
intelligence is usually uh magic and
then pyromancy is a glove that you level
up and there's not snap stat attached to
it but that is not the case anymore
um so i say we just get started
yeah it probably won't matter that much
down the road
you do you i prefer playing as a dude
okay
i prefer playing as a game
game body type b for boobas
[Laughter]
medallion and laid with crimson amber
increases magic maximum hp spoiled prawn
i think that's what we want
the gold grace shining in the eyes of
the people of the lands between who gain
many runes golden seed
a golden seed washed ashore from the
lands between said the rainforest sacred
flasks hmm that's pretty good jacob oh
now the famed imp ashes the ashes of
small
diminutive golems ashes are said to hold
spirits within
three strange cracked pots that somehow
mend themselves a container for certain
thrown items
two stones shaped like swords break the
seals of the statues but can only be
used once
i
as is the case with every souls game in
the beginning we have no idea what that
means what any of this means
technically john get out of here it's
the elden dream souls
five secret branches charged with
beguiling powers said to
five pieces of boiled prawn
boosted physical damage negation dad oh
you came
likeness of a noble whose eyes have been
gouged out attracts enemies aggression
yeah okay that's exactly that's this is
dark souls shabriri's whoa
um
the sacred boss was the most appealing
sacred
where is it i don't know
that seems like very very useful yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i feel like that's the best at
every game it's just something very
practical at the beginning pretty much
should we do the random
oh yeah all right yeah everyone close
your eyes
all right loner
detailed appearance
mature
similar face
you doing random again
oh
oh no it's gonna be so hard to make a
crazy ass face why because normally you
just
oh yeah yeah oh well you can still
customize all of it
oh you're doing this very differently to
me i would put hours in this camera oh
my god this is gonna when this game
comes out and i'm like doing this myself
i want to be in this for so long hours
literally hours we're making you
done okay my hairline's not that bad
[Music]
[Laughter]
it really does just go off his head just
right up there yeah
like a little hat
it's just the eye let's let's bros
oh
baby berries and cream cut
then 23 is probably the closest to my
head well we're not going to beat you
nice bang are you gonna use this save or
are you gonna start a new one
it depends what we do depends on how far
we get depends on how terrible i do like
that bulk i like this one yeah it's nice
i like haircuts that hide the eyebrows
yeah we didn't we'll just do no eyebrows
i don't have any there you go cool
yeah nothing to hide
oh in the beard
do they have soul patch
goatee
oh i like that mustache
that's a gentleman that is yeah that was
the haircut yeah we're gonna be the we
look like the snake charmer from ranking
of kings
there's a reference to very few people
upstairs oh everyone's gonna get that
all right oh we got a big hype irises
wow this is very detailed you'd love to
see it oh no
i love it
it is time to hear from one of our
sponsors anchor this is the ankawak b600
video bar it has an all-in-one design
and very neatly integrates a video
camera speakers microphone array and a
dimmable key light all inside just one
small footprint it keeps your desk neat
and organized for efficient work
environments and in my opinion i don't
know i think it just looks really sleek
okay this is me recording using the anka
work b600 video bar and the built-in
microphone
this quality is incredible this might be
the best webcam
that i own and i own several it's very
good it also has ai powered noise
reduction voice radar technology
combined with dynamic beam forming and
an ai algorithm allows users to achieve
full duplex clear calls even in noisy
environments it has excellent video
performance with 2k graphics fov
adjustments auto focus and image
enhancement the video camera portion
provides the optimum streaming solution
there's also a built-in key light as you
can see
it uses a very cool technology that
delivers automated lighting adjustment
via an adjustable built-in led panel to
make sure users look their best in any
lighting color temperature and
brightness can also be further adjusted
via the app so if you want to check out
your own work b600 video bar check out
the link in the description
i mean john's seen the characters i've
made like my bloodborne character just
looked exactly like me yeah
that's cool
yeah i wish i had some pictures of like
well into foe in elite dangerous didn't
you oh that does christopher walken oh
i don't know i made ryan
no i remember that
maybe with you yeah john made
oh yeah for the for the race
yeah it was really funny yeah it was
super funny everybody thought it was
really funny yeah it's because it was
accurate
i keep wanting to comedically splash
drinks on people's faces but i know that
it's not worth it but i so badly wanted
to choose well if it was mexican coke
[Laughter]
so pretty that is pretty
kind of like it yeah
look at all these options
this is how you you do your makeup
yeah
this sliders all the way to the right
that's me okay i say we stop wasting
time oh you don't want to have a tattoo
oh sure i don't feel like this is time
wasting this is pivotal yeah oh my gosh
guys i just want to kill things
wow look at these so our hair is hiding
all of our tattoos oh these little head
tattoos oh there's no
you have them on your nose get an
i like it
i hate that why i don't know why you
would rotate it
the symmetry was perfect
and now it's off by one notch i like
that it looks like
look it's like um
oh my god john
they'll always keep it that way no
[Music]
and fix it
you can have an eye patch hold on oh you
can yeah yeah
yeah
oh it's just like mia yeah we made 2b
just as sexy no i think sexier
kinky yeah
no eyebrows no eyes
i like it all right
alter body i don't know it's pretty good
should i be turned on
john what is the first souls what are
our souls boys guy look like he was a
horrific mess right yeah i don't
remember i think it was just like a
randomized uh nightmare
no
oh we've got the abs like uh what's that
guy come on dabs that you was like oh
everybody knows that your head is
directly proportionate to the size of
your chest yeah
yeah yeah
that's crevice abs yeah he's got that
big canyon in his ass yep
say favorites all right all right for
when you know when you do your
playthrough yeah
[Music]
jacob
um
uh it should be
uh crandall
crandall's pretty good yeah
oh yeah i would have spelled it like
randall
no it's just candles
okay
okay let's go let's [ __ ] all right
everyone shut up
this is a big moment
all right it's learning
i really hope there's a big esoteric
cutscene oh they're 100 is
didn't that leak
with the opening sequence i've been kind
of avoiding i've been avoiding
everything
they put on a new trailer today shut it
we should watch it before we play
no it's more else
the game's going to crash yeah it's
going to crash
2d art
game is not bad
it's a departure
i don't know it's pictures
that's very pretty
i know i want that on my bathroom
oh it does good reference jacob good
memories
oh she's the queen
[Music]
and in the night of the black knights
god win the golden
god win
i mean
yeah i mean i guess
soon
americans they're all wins
that
[Laughter]
there you go
all right i'm back to my chair oh my god
what was that
a massive it was like a
oh yeah there's the giant guy who rides
a tiny horse
that's a very cool part of that
yeah
one time ago
those moving pictures
rise now
he tarnished oh you're dead we will oh
you have to live we're trying man
i wonder which dog
so this guy brings respect to life
that was always
the thing you just kind of wake up yeah
i guess in dark souls 1 you're in the
cell
yeah who put you there
i bet you foxy
oh these bosses are something but he's
all like oh yeah i mean i feel like
sometimes in the trailer it shows the
main characters and those are always the
big
big hitters yeah
whoa
1890s
scuba
which turner shall arise i wonder oh god
not crandall
[Laughter]
anyone but crandall
cussing over him
yeah look at her gnarled knuckles i
don't know that that's our hand i think
that might be the hand of the person
bringing his back maybe
is
okay but isn't the ring broken
isn't that what they're saying it
shattered
maybe it's more abstract
you can come to elder ward yeah i think
they said that elder ring isn't actually
a ring
yeah this ain't no lord of the
of the what
i'm not sure oh okay
i forgot the reference
yeah lord of the elden got it yeah
come on gabe okay
oh you have a gesture oh cool
it's ring that's great all right oh we
have a map
wow yeah
cool it's so detailed
it says what time of day it is that's
cool you got a shield and an axe other
people
yeah it's got to be all the reviewers
yeah
i know how to use an equipment related a
big thank you to bandai for giving us
code really appreciate that
you're supposed to say that once
in every episode yeah thank you code
provided away right now we're definitely
going to read the lore on some of the
things we find yes
that's cool with me we should be doing
that yeah can we go up to each of these
ghosts and ask which one is game
informer
jacob go for it
the memory of first grace which once
guided by god tarnished to the lands
between lose our runes and return to
last sight of grace visited it is merely
a cycle
stand before the elden ring become
the elder
and the elder
ew put it back
gross
be broken and uncertain claim your place
is held in lord that's no there's no way
a person broke down no it would be like
let's like no yeah there's always a
bunch in the beginning yeah it'll be
like touch butt hole or yeah that was on
my finger but yeah
that is a good one um but we're also not
playing when it's public yet i don't
think press does that no
well those were press running around
yeah
but you're right the beginning usually
does have actual why is it always
defeating one by one why is the y
capital
what what why is the s not capitalized
maybe y is a person it was written in
haste
so why is the action [ __ ] crazy
10 out of 10 game of the year can we
look at crandall's face yeah like we see
some crandall
so this wasn't where the
[Laughter]
this wasn't where um
the [ __ ] starting zone the thing was
for the network test yeah it's different
cool this is the beginning this is the
true beginning
so the network test was like a character
that was already made or something yeah
you had a few options
to choose it just wasn't the whole menu
and and you started with like a bunch of
[ __ ]
like spells and stuff okay and
supposedly all like the spells a lot
yeah all the summons you got way easier
like it's a lot more work to get him
in the real game nice john off the
beaten path medial
there isn't a beaten path that's the
problem right that's that's the elden
ring
secret stupid words
okay
appraise it
rated good rated good for good every
good
[Laughter]
they'll know something
and then also
jump look at that you
guys there are mounts now oh my god
another thing is that uh
the enemy placement all the placement of
everything in the network test was
not where it is
that's cool yeah time for sacrifice and
then visions of cave
okay does that mean we have to die oh
this looks like a place where die yeah
oh what was that
oh
okay
hey handsome adopted scion crap a big
crab man oh my god that is so well
animated that's awesome holy crap oh i
crouched into sneak mode oh john you're
gonna kill us
get out of crouch oh my god
oh yeah blocking is a thing it is wow
okay well
let's get it as you can tell i've been
dark souls 23 or so times it is very
difficult to animate uh anything that
has multiple clips
um and they've done a very good job you
did they did a good job with that what
do you mean like anything more than a
snake
no anything that has like more than one
arm and no legs no more than what
general standard being a human things
with multiple limbs other than
human standard
oh no okay i think you were meant to die
though yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah some
nerd's gonna be but uh like you could
have died i'm sorry for all you souls
boys out there i failed
jacob would have done it yeah probably
not a lot of that on the second try
no mention of me that's fine
we're equal
yeah okay yeah sure why not jacob yeah
exactly
oh
why is its front leg bending backwards
like that
that's how they go that's how they do
i think no their back legs do that not
their front legs they have like six
knees
oh also i use a lot of audio cues when i
fight so
that's why i died there yeah yeah
torrent that's the name of our steed
torrent
this is the girl with the hat i want
this for us one of her kind is sure
you talking about the lady the blueberry
but i suppose not
i want dwarven even if it does give us
torrent game
then order
wonder what happens if you beat that
crab
impossible some nerd's gonna be there
you probably go through a door and then
die to something else yeah yeah like a
trap or something yeah like in demon
souls yeah gives you the old ball down
the stairs so rude the first time i saw
that it doesn't dark souls too though
so rude
dark souls 2. i said dark souls comma 2
dark souls as well
and also in dark souls
well that if you beat asylum demon on
first try you get his weapon
cool
only needs those black firebombs
nice but where is us
that's your kind of manner
yeah i remember these knowledge lies
below
hello
ghost hello
wait this looks like the starting area
of of the network test oh okay
yeah you just jump off
can we just i'm skipping off can we eat
that finger we found
we can
and we will but why
oh it's so dark john that's your fault
john
you made it so dark
yes
perhaps oh should we change it
nah i think we're okay we just have to
get out to the world where is it oh
it's every time bud love seeing his
it face be in here it could be in here
compelling
not in that okay
nice hell yeah real gamer
it's probably in the [ __ ] main menu
yeah it's fine one of those things you
can't change it it didn't say it oh it
did say to make it barely visible and
you went there you go that's basically
look it's barely visible
you can't see that
i mean extremely bad
i can no i can still there now you can't
see it now
that
there we go all right it's where it was
when it started
give that tree this one it's one up
thank you i know
it's just one it's one up it's locked oh
that guy told us to jump yeah he was
supposed to
that looked like a death hole
but then why would he tell you to jump
this game would never play tricky tricks
like that no souls born games never tell
you why the map is just a world map yes
okay but you're inside us maybe this is
hug world right touch grace
fog wall
oh but it's just a barrier not yet
interesting you but you didn't want to
interact with that statue right now
oh that's the finger oh okay this is
players
sure
oh is was that one of the things we
could start with
stone sword key maybe i don't remember
all i remember was that boiled prawn
oh yeah carefully almost unelevated oh
it's gonna be secret secrets
it always makes me sick to find secrets
because you're just spinning yeah
all right
going up into the world yeah i think
this is the next
thanksgiving good luck ahead you don't
know that i'm going to be getting a
he's also not um
she slides backwards when she sits it's
so funny
yeah
yeah we know how bond fighting
[Laughter]
you're gonna regret this
so
i wonder about detail
i think it'll it'll get
breath of wild
this guy just shits on us right we just
have to explore more
[Laughter]
oh my
[Music]
i wish we can't all be people of color
i'll blow check it out
problem solved
beautiful look at us we look great there
we go
go on
after you tell it it's going to be a
problem come on
get doug
what if i pat you over here wouldn't
that be nice can you imagine if you got
a pad
that was very cool come on
he told us something important yeah he
said we die
so we're gonna die here i think he was
like the guy at
fire link where he's just like you have
to go find things yep
and you won't succeed you stupid [ __ ]
we have to meet somebody who laughs at
us i just want you to break the thoughts
john it's like really upsetting me i'm
not doing it
there you go
where are you going back to the hole
yeah i'm gonna go check the hole
there's something up there jumping in
hole
we're getting some frame rate drops for
sure that's happening
yeah i am dying i believe we are playing
without the day one patch for context
internet
wait a second
oh that guy definitely
he got in that hole somehow
there are things there's a ledge yeah
you you can die if you fall the wrong
way i think what the fall damage is like
yeah
i know you want john to party but he's
in game online
okay so immediately divergence that's
awesome yeah get away from me
i'm a gamer boy
sight of grace okay it's giving us the
same message
so these are like our bonfires yeah
but then there's also little statues
where you'll spawn at
hi sir
go today so our first kill of the game
oh my god
how do you oh i missed the message this
goober got killed by that guy you know
how to do it [ __ ] games
right is it a d-pad thing
try d-pad
good
call maybe not
oh okay no that's d-pads to switch
things okay
good thinking good thing i really like
the way they look
there's always something kind of scary
about the normal bad guys and these what
if i hold it like he's wearing a mosque
oh okay hold why push r1
use an almond continue okay
yeah i think we are occasionally losing
some frames that's fine
i think for the most part it's okay
new game what's this no no i meant the
webcam but that would be because of the
cpu oh i see it yeah
i'm going to stay completely still the
whole time
oh who's that oh
oh yeah
yeah for crafting oh my god
the one thing
we needed what was that what was that
guy up there he's a crossbow boy oh he's
just shooting at you
doing his darndest don't worry we'll
find him
oh kick huh a spearmint wait
okay it doesn't look like kick is the
same wielding opponents oh
okay so there is no kick
i might be on a different button
so that means
so does that mean like you could like
two-hand whatever is in your left hand
alternatively
no
yeah i think so
nice
yeah full defense
do i not have stamina oh whoa what the
[ __ ] was that oh it actually hurts them
yeah wait was that a running attack
a little bit a little watch i did like a
front flip did you guys see that yeah
how did i do it like quite a bit of
damage that's that's tight
how do i do fluff with my foot here come
all the running beat people gonna do
dual shield runs of this game before we
know it
yeah taking down bosses with a shield
yeah
really creepy
oh yeah dual shield run what's the thing
in what ds2
i have no idea because you had a
uh power stance which they brought back
[Laughter]
yeah somehow that guy knew we were
maidenless
yeah i didn't say anything about john
though
wait no maidenlist is technically an
insult actually yeah
oh stealth yes
what you doing there bud you just
digging that rock he's looking for
truffles
oh stealth bushes i want my pizza dude
yeah
he says a bunch of things in that way
he's just like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] seattle
what a good movie it's such an
interesting movie
charge attack is hold rt rt while
jumping
oh did you jump
okay well you had your shield that was
not effective it wasn't the shield this
time though maybe you should do the
shield
oh nice
so we did
there's stagger basically and then you
can do a repost rather than having to
parry
so you like break their stance and then
you do your yeah big attack that's cool
yeah see if you can do the oh
okay so jumping in tag is only with rt
so yeah these are the things that these
are checkpoints
that are location based uh yeah i think
it's like when you go into a dungeon so
the campfires the grace is different
yeah the grace is where if you're on the
open world
that's real goat and you can fast travel
between graces yeah and then these
appear when you go into like dungeons or
specific areas and i think the grace
will also point you in the right
direction oh right they said yeah points
like the light yeah
yes
[Music]
immediately after blocking an attack
interesting oh i don't think we knew
this last time we played
oops i went too early
oh cool
that's awesome
oh my [ __ ]
they're gonna go it definitely makes
like playing with a shield more
interesting
little [ __ ] because that was like
playing with the shield in previous
games always felt a little bit boring
yeah like actually having more stuff to
it it makes it cool
i feel like i'm
all you souls boys are going to be
mocking me for my gameplay no you're
doing great games
oh look maybe back up
oh cool it was worth it it was worth it
how do we do stains i'm so struggling
oh over here oh it's all in one menu
let's see a ring
no it says oh nice
ah
i love it
nice wood crandall great foam great foam
oh and you can just hold it it's slow
like yoga
okay
strength
fighting
cool that was a that was a good detour
nice little uh area
frames
it's all good we ain't got no day one
patch you slayed your face
[ __ ] who's gets it uh three
weeks early yeah
that's right it's january
oh it's like d and d yeah but you have
to collect them oh yeah yeah
don't mansplain
alana
that's bad yeah
don't do that oh okay so i allocated yes
three yeah yeah oh we don't have any of
these dude
oh you passed time i have always liked
that it still lets you say like you yeah
use this thing but the game will be like
oh you don't have you don't have it you
[ __ ] idiot
[ __ ]
go get one first fast travel
and then we'll talk about allocating
your flasks
can we not fast travel no i don't think
you like mommy
oh you get like it's the only one you've
seen you've only seen that one we saw
one up next to the [ __ ]
did we
sit at it
did i not i don't think we touched it oh
nightmare randy savage i love it
and i also like that it's like the
sort of head guard looks like a wig off
top yeah
it looks like a trash bag
wow you know what a hero what a being
the future elden lore absolutely
[Music]
so i just skipped this yeah just got a
nice touch i think we just you know
who's the guy that we fought
the soldier no no no dart sorry during
the network
margaret yeah margaret yeah margaret
there's a horseman down there yeah the
horseman is in the network
i never beat him
because i think he's probably easier
when you have the mouth
that's just like yogurt
it's just like yogurt
it is just like yogurt he really is
crazy he moves
oh my god that damage yeah i don't think
you're meant to fight him i think he's
there to like talk if he's there fight
him okay so we're rolling i think you're
supposed to fight him
she's not that hard
oh my god
that's okay the the
great spot was right there
i just wonder what about him makes him a
tree sentiment specifically he guards
the trees
he's doing a good job well there's a
giant golden tree maybe he's like of
that order i can't wait to get just like
railroaded by that guy
jake
[Music]
so the runes are your like souls or your
blood echoes yeah okay
big little pilot rooms we had
there you go we got so many it's pretty
it looks like it's like a little plant
yeah i like all the tree imagery yeah
those big old trees this is so pretty
oh animals kill them and take their
pelts
should we turn the quality
yeah you could try but i mean i can like
i can run at anything really like well
i'm going to destroy in here so it's
it's the it's the game
that's cheap just like droidico away
from you yeah did you see that
that was just a normal ass sheep it's a
crystal drag or crystal lizard no it's
just a crystal
oh no some kind of beast
oh it's dead now interesting
no okay it's just a little soul soul
popper
so yeah where are we gonna get somebody
to talk to anywhere isn't it
santa claus yeah santa
what the [ __ ]
merry little man
i can see it judgmental that you're not
then why not purchase a little something
okay defender
i love
thankfully we got hella money cookbook
oh
crafting repertoire crafting kit that's
probably
necessary yeah
i'm really interested to see what this
is all about yeah
ooh
oh
what is that
it i think it's like
potions important knowledge in brief oh
maybe it's like recipes
so yeah yeah
interesting
let's read our notes of knowledge you
see there's an about kale option too oh
really yeah we could learn all about our
little santa claus i dude i'm skipping
everything i'm sorry guys yeah you
should not i mean all this is like
reflex i've played dark souls so many
times would you say well you can't
assume that the viewers who are watching
this for the first time have i don't
give a [ __ ]
no no i meant that i just have the habit
of skipping everything because i've
played yeah
yeah i've been playing dying light too
so i'm also in skip at everything mode
okay and
i guess so cool no
like shirts
shorts no shops yeah shirts
did that sheep give us anything when we
murdered it you got some thin bones
yeah thin beast bones this is probably
useful for something
good
do you just exclaim after you hiccup
sometimes i get shocked by my own
hiccups yeah
[Laughter]
i didn't do
this the hiccups are the only thing that
like pissed me off oh dude they get very
annoying it's gonna be painful where's
the [ __ ]
oh it's right above it i'm an idiot we
need two smithing stones
how many do we have one all right gave
us one
all right sounds like we gotta keep
adventuring yeah we do what is that kill
it oh it's already dead all we've done
is just crushed some skulls oh
yeah we killed that that two guys that
two got two guys oh what another sheep
gotta get nice and stuffy
don't forget to pick the fruits
buds as well you can [ __ ] those birds up
oh my god this game is so pretty i know
never came i'm so happy
i can't wait to climb up that cliff in
the background dude that'd be sick
nice one yeah
all right okay here's where we learn if
there's fall damage okay oh there's all
those big boys
there is definitely fold out
no there's
not well what a fast you died spring
it's not wasting any time
it expects us to die a lot of issues
yeah
all that that adds up when you by the
time you finish the gram you've saved
about uh
three hours yeah on death screens
because of the sped up animation
all right that way
it's cool
yeah
it's interesting that your sprint
doesn't weigh stamina either i mean i
guess it makes sense for the world yeah
he's [ __ ] hiccups now it's you
jerking in the corner of my eye
oh a bunch of little fragments
crafting the teeth
sorry i can't help a lot
this is one of those things that like
you just can't hide ever
no
no don't have a chance can't contain it
i wish
is that little waypoint is that your
runes yes yeah that's awesome yeah
because i would never find them again
after dying
there haven't been any waypoints for
like
uh
you know like oh check out this house or
check out this or that that's kind of
cool though um
no i mean i think i know the direction
that you're supposed to be headed in
yeah
that eagle has i don't want to hit them
that's yours you do you
evil guy oh no it doesn't have your
roots that's good i was hoping it didn't
let me just fly away with your
goodies
there we go oh that was a cuter animal
[Music]
yes
so oh is it a consumable that we
oh where's the
did we not buy a recipe
[Music]
oh it's literally a tip
oh it's telling you where something is
oh
it's like a little treasure map third
church america north of the mist so it's
a note about a flask of wondrous physics
interesting
that's cool i like that crosstalk white
bridge you follow the animal trail north
beautiful it's like morrowind
you want to fight them you use right for
this i fought them in the network test
they don't give you [ __ ]
if you have a hard time
see anything from them nothing but a
hard time i mean there is that weird
monster on the beach down there oh yeah
the weird like squid things so
this is gonna be the whole hour is me
just falling off of things
i want to see that thing whoa
i'm going to ring his bell i know that's
so cool
damn
all right well back to the
i can't wait till we have a special
steed to ride did i even have any rooms
is little prism stones is this like a
pause menu or are you like no no yeah
you're missing
i should have known
feed torrent
oh cool oh thrown behind you tonight so
toronto's gonna be our steed
spoilers game
oh hell yeah bone darts
it's really it's a
it's a crafting item but you can put it
on your inventory you can just like
throw them as an object or something
all right
the runes where'd you go
yes
exactly
give us your beast bones
oh did i jump down yeah i was down there
it was right i think you're making the
same mistake if you drop the same way
again no i mean it's i jumped down it's
up there oh yeah okay let's go around
around
the orb
it's a skull
yummy
a golden rule look pretty silver to me
oh pick the flower nice
bird leaf
some [ __ ] fantasy
ah yes
the earth
the leaves of the herd plant yeah are
you sure it's right here
yeah at the edge
is it in the bushes there it's hiding
oh it's the place where you jumped yeah
it's usually like no but i've lost souls
millions of times from falling down
something and it's usually like five ten
seconds behind the location of where you
died
and yeah so yeah if you fall off
somewhere it'll be at the top but again
i have lost souls by falling and not
being able to retrieve them because that
didn't happen
oh
no you're thinking of a different game
okay
these are perfect you see
i've had it once for like i touched
a little like
it's happening
while you're falling yeah
the great hollow
um where there's all those different
branches
like i'll fall slip off of a branch a
smaller branch and then fall to my death
and it'll be on that little smaller
branch that i've bounced off that makes
sense oh yeah i remember these things
what the [ __ ] is this
squid
their attacks aren't really that crazy
though so you probably take one
that's not some kind of squid
nonsense yeah that is not a lot of
damage also do you not have any spells
right now no
it also didn't do a lot of damage to you
there we go
it's just gonna be a
war of attrition guys i
[ __ ] you that's basically the same thing
i'll level up somehow yeah we did it
that one seems content to just
continue on its way
oh that's so gross yeah i love it oh
that was a beast yeah you love it i
think there's a beaky boy
sparkles
don't worry about that
oh sorry about that he's still following
us yeah
oh look some sea birds some penguins
penguins
sparkly
yeah what is this
opinion four toads foul foot what is it
oh is it like a korok
or something invisible and deadly
wait
how cool yeah what is it
maybe there's a interact hit it with
your ass but it fronts yeah i reckon you
act at the right time
axe
okay i'll act at the right time this is
straight up i mean it looks like the
koroks that dart around yeah
here comes
come on [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah
chase it
it's too fast we'll catch you around the
bench yeah
maybe it's something like where we need
like a spell or item to see yeah it
could be
ring of singing
yeah i know i i think we're good oh
that's so cool i love the trees let's
kill another sea bird yeah just [ __ ] up
some old buds
die that was like
that was like [ __ ] incredible
don't copy me
hello
hey cutie are you a samurai
acquire materials did you just steal
that from him no you picked up the
butterflies
oh stripper white oh gosh
from a human
squids no i don't hit him hit him
you might need him later
you get one month
yeah are you sure i shouldn't hit him uh
i don't want to in case you need him at
some point oh he's going up
oh you pissed him off
i think he was just chilling i think he
was but he didn't want to bury the enemy
i wonder if you can carry while blocking
oh you can it's like dark souls one
nice
oh
so there's a real hit there's a real hit
yeah the first strike in the field oh he
did a little a little brown little piss
and it was stronger
oh
i was trying to do a jump strike
[Laughter]
you can do that i think you go back and
do it yeah oh yeah that's not so bad
yeah it's just an enemy on the beach oh
god i'm out of practice
it happens i feel ashamed
it's your first time playing this one
you'll be good
i'm coming for you freaking
scimitar man
this is where i spend all my time in
these games stubbornly fighting an enemy
that keeps beating me over and over
that's like a three-minute walk yeah
oh there's that island that i couldn't
get to before yeah is there a path i
think maybe it's something that we
unlock later yeah when we get like jesus
powers for our horse exactly yeah
there's like an underground that's what
it says in the guide must get jesus
powers for hosts before cross bridge
deep water is my worst enemy in these
games oh yeah
yeah when we did soul toys uh
jacob died
more times to the lake where the hydra
is than to any other boss no way
just falling in the water yeah
hello sir lodgeman
he's just
[Music]
where do we find
that lady that lets this level
um you have to go past santa
and to that encampment
right maybe we should go there because
we'll get a horse oh and he'll get a
whole straight there which will make
this hole run so much faster yeah
well get her it's fine yeah get our
runes and then get horse is that guy's
still following you know he gave up i
think he chucked something at you though
he's doing the classic dark souls
like walk back yeah i'm watching you oh
you damn it
i want
this is going to be like an invisible
rolling sheep
it's going to be korok
oh [ __ ] you penguin
[ __ ] flying [ __ ]
all the frame rate drops always happen
like when you attack dude i know it's
it's we can we can drop settings down
just to see if it helps when we attack
or an enemy attacks
yeah that's why i keep dying all right
here's the show now you can sneak up on
he knows you're there but
you stick up on
nice i really thought you were gonna
miss
oh he's grumpy
nice
oh it's a follow-up
no why don't you do that then
you're good you're good
why are you taking risks
you're a weak baby
naked
play it safe not to put a horseless
chair all right yeah let's go get the
horse yep
i only have seven minutes left
i want to meet this guy
yeah he looks cool but oh it's raining
was it raining
oh beautiful
look at all these
oh
oh horse man yeah tree said no still
wandering around yeah i didn't beat him
in the
night my test
yeah we'll change the frames when we
start the next recording
hour two
rooms
do you keep them i guess you only lose
your runes yeah yeah
a golden light shining through
what is that i know follow it no no no
the thing that was um
did we not get this either no we didn't
though john
we've just been ignoring them well i
mean they're not that visible i feel
like it's just kind of just go outside
and touch some grace
oh it's so pretty it is very basically
scary after the riot walking in the
bushes there is a man with a torch uh
jacob's number one phobia oh no no no
the man have tortured oh god oh god
hello kind sir
so easy it's not the fire i forgot that
stealth is a thing the man part freaks
me out
yeah yes queen
same as this little dog down here oh wow
she is taking up the floor
i shall be known as the one who slayed
the mighty crandall
which no one has done before it was
quite easy you see
he was naked mostly i want to parry
now
i feel like i'm
i again i think you just need to just
[ __ ] level up
i mean the graves right there
touch first
there we go nice that looks like it was
too early but i'll take it
i love it because they have iframes like
they're invincible when they're standing
up yeah but you time it to where the
moment they like
they're like oh and then you smack them
dead
well the animation we're getting up even
when they get hit stuff it's just like
yeah
it's so slow
oh there's a ball
nice
dead
who goes there who's that who are you
they're lost some games journalist is
lost in the woods
where that borgo i know
give us your beast bones
lump of flesh aren't we all delicious
am i going the right way to you all
going the right way generally i think
yeah
that was glowy thing
oh there's a little statue
nice all right it's cool
you could applaud you're just like
taking it yeah
ruins yourself
are you looking at me
well somebody clapped and you got
excited oh i'm sorry
exciting
oh
[Music]
so aerodynamic you know
you stealth there's like one bush
yeah
you unfortunately can't hide your scent
you can avoid this whole camp if you
want to
you don't want to be some kind of [ __ ]
there's smack on my lips i'm so excited
to play elder
what was that
there we go sakura of these people
you didn't dance
what if i stealth too
[Applause]
myself two-handed yeah
hello oh
hello
time for attention
oh cool oh yeah at least you look cool
they were like
that [ __ ] was stupid but really cool
oh hello sir oh [ __ ] this is why i want
to know how to kick
uh do you want to check the controller
to see if there is a kick is it like a
double push forward situation
it could be
like a sakura yeah
i meant to say seafood but
he either applies
kick that's my go-to move in seafood
that's a good move
no no oh no yeah you got him maybe he's
let out of school
[Music]
oh no not the gate oh i remember here it
shows up here though this is where a
woman appeared well
half lady okay
those are good moves well the other lot
they're just sort of chilling back there
so well they let their commander get all
the glory yeah
oh
you should never roll away from a sphere
for one hour we are let's leave it there
wow that is episode one of our elven
ring playthrough we made it i'm sorry i
disappointed you all right over to jacob